last night
as the missiles were raining down in
ukraine from russia kiev all over the
country as russian troops were pouring
in from belarus and in from crimea and
over into the dunets and luhans because
all of this is happening
trump
goes on fox news
is interviewed by laura ingraham
and says
this all happened because of the rigged
of the wrecked election um
i mean guys
let's just listen look probably ever we
were energy independent and he blew
we're just we're just learning that u.s
officials are looking at a potential
amphibious landing now
in odessa ukraine again
a month ago or three weeks ago all the
so-called experts were saying that you
know putin was probably going to just
be content with staying in those
separatist regions
uh but i think given what's unfolded
sadly with a lot of weakness in the
united states
they just decided to go for it right so
laura tees it up and says
putin probably so like they were so
wrong about the intelligence these
people
we had all the intel and it's like it
really looks like they're planning an
invasion they're like no no no no and
now they're saying well
we were wrong but because we didn't
think the u.s would be so weak to cause
the invasion and trump just teased it
you know she teased it up and trump hits
it out of the park as far as they're
concerned
it looks like they're going for it and
where does that leak nato the nato
alliance
i think you're exactly right i think
that's what happened he was going to be
satisfied with the beast and now he sees
the weakness and the incompetence and
the stupidity of this administration and
as an american i'm angry about it and
i'm saddened by it and it all happened
because of a rigged election this would
have never happened that includes
inflation and that includes millions of
people pouring in on a monthly basis far
more than three million people and
they're coming from 129 different
countries wait a second so
putin's invading russia
because you falsely believe the election
was stolen from you and undocumented
immigrants from latin america are coming
to the united states this is a bizarre
foreign policy analysis we have no idea
what's happening and they're destroying
our country president trump we actually
have just hold on i'm so sorry to
interrupt you but we have uh we're going
to the yeah they're going to something
so moments later this is this is just
incredible moments later
trump seems to think that laura ingram
told him that the u.s has launched an
attack on ukraine and trump's like you
shouldn't have said that
and laura ingram has to say no no no the
russians launched an amphibious attack
on ukraine guys trump seems to think
that the story is the us invaded the
invaded ukraine i
monitor this continue to monitor
statements um we'll go back to president
trump for a quick reaction uh we had a
kind of a really pathetic display from
the ukrainian president zielinski
earlier today president trump where he
in russian he doesn't like to speak
russian but in russian he was
essentially imploring vladimir putin not
to invade his country um
and now we basically have the ukrainian
ambassador to the united nation nations
looking like a defeated man all right
you guys ready for this listen to this
uh your final reaction
well i think the whole thing again would
have never happened it shouldn't happen
and it's a very sad thing but you know
what's also very dangerous is you told
me about the amphibious attacks
by americans you shouldn't be saying
that because you and everybody else
shouldn't know about it they should do
that secretly not be doing that through
the great laura ingraham they should be
doing that secretly nobody should know
that laura and you know
that was the russians those are the now
those are the russian the russian uh
amphibious laws i thought you said that
i thought you said
officials
she said u.s officials
you know
are seeing that there's an amphibious
attack happening imagine being so
dazed and clueless
that in the midst of russia invading
ukraine
and the us clearly being on the side
that russia is in the wrong as a former
president you believe that what's
happening is the us has launched an
amphibious attack and invasion of
ukraine
guys we're screwed
we're screwed um here's one last very
strange uh uh segment from this
interview if uh any western nation or
any nation intervenes with this russian
military action
well this is something that should have
never happened this would not have
happened during my administration in
fact some people were saying why didn't
this state take place uh over the last
four years
during our administration and it didn't
for a very good reason and i'll explain
that to you someday
very soon the evidence is going to come
forward about why this invasion
does not take place one day
trump will explain why it didn't take
place under his watch unhinged
unhint global laughingstock
the level of aggression
of putin
is matched only by the level of
ignorance
of donald trump at the same time as this
invasion is going on
if you're like me you love documentaries
and you should really check out our
sponsor curiosity stream the only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries curiosity stream has a
better selection of documentaries than
netflix hulu and amazon they always have
the newest and most critically acclaimed
titles including a bunch of stuff i
can't find anywhere else i just finished
watching fiddlin it's about bluegrass i
know so little about bluegrass
it's pretty fascinating and i watched a
documentary about it fiddlin
i've been using curiosity stream for
over a year i always have it going on my
tv in the evenings you really can't run
out of the amazing content constantly
adding new stuff if you want to deep
dive into a thought-provoking new topic
they have documentaries if you just want
to unwind and turn your brain off
they have documentaries there as well
right now curiosity stream is giving my
audience 25 off that comes out to just
14.99
a year a year that's just a dollar 25 a
month go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below